[Musique]
et notre invité politique ce matin c'est
Jean-François Copé bonjour merci
beaucoup d'être avec nous mère de mon
membre des républicains on est ensemble
pendant 20 minutes pour une interview en
partenariat avec la presse régionale
représentée par Stéphane Vernet de
Ouest-France bonjour Stéphane bonjour
bonjour on va commencer en parlant du
Maroc Jean-François Copé un prêt de 3000
morts dans le séisme au Maroc et parmi
eux un couple qui était originaire de
votre ville on imagine que l'émotion est
grande du côté de Meaux est-ce que votre
ville a prévu quelque chose pour venir
en aide au sinistré oui
on a été bouleversé nous un mot parce
que il se trouve que c'est un
jeune ménage que on connaissait bien qui
venait tout juste de se marier
le père de Yuna c'est donc beau-père de
Samira travail dans notre mairie donc
voilà il y a beaucoup beaucoup
d'émotions à Meaux aujourd'hui et puis
bien sûr au-delà de de cette de leur
disparition tragique nous avons nous
évidemment un lien très fort avec le
Maroc fin comme tous les Français et les
franco-marocains et donc bien sûr que
nous allons nous mobiliser on a commencé
à le faire relayer les appels au don et
puis évidemment on va on va regarder au
niveau de notre communauté
d'agglomération du Pays de mots pour
proposer évidemment une subvention un
don comme on le fait en pareil
circonstances même si tout cela se fait
dans des conditions tragiques et
j'espère que la France pourra aider le
mieux possible malgré les aléas
politiques alors justement le Maroc a
accepté l'aide de 4 pays là la
Grande-Bretagne l'Espagne le Qatar et
les Émirats arabes unis mais pas la
France comment est-ce que vous
interprétez cela est-ce que ça veut dire
que les relations entre la France et le
et le Maroc sont détériorés à ce point
c'est triste je veux dire c'est moi je
suis un ami du Maroc depuis toujours et
je vois avec beaucoup de tristesse la
dégradation des relations diplomatiques
entre nos deux pays depuis ces dernières
années en plus je les comprends pas très
bien parce que les choix qui ont été
faits par le président français sont
difficiles à comprendre entre l'Algérie
et le Maroc compte tenu tout ce qui s'y
passe une Algérie qui en réalité pour
toute une série de raisons du point de
vue gouvernemental fait de la France un
bouc émissaire traditionnel et on en
sortira pas avant très longtemps de
l'autre le Maroc qui est un ami de la
France avec lequel nous avons des
relations très fortes économiques
culturelles c'est difficile à c'est
difficile à admettre et dans le même
temps et bien la dégradation elle
conduit à ce genre de situation qui
devrait pas avoir lieu en fait parce que
dans ces moments là il y a pas de
politique il faut évidemment aider les
victimes donc oui bien sûr je suis très
triste ça oui le gouvernement français a
débloqué 5 millions d'euros tout de
suite mais pour les ONG est-ce que ça
c'est la bonne façon de faire
dans ces cas-là on fait comme on peut
bien sûr on va parler d'un autre sujet
en parler de la question de
l'immigration il y a une trib ce matin
qui est publié dans le journal
Libération tribune de parlementaire de
la majorité présidentielle et de la
nuque sauf la France insoumise pour
demander la régularisation des métiers
en tension c'est là ligne rouge de la
droite est-ce que cette tribune montre
que ce texte est volé l'échec en tout
cas il bat de l'aile comme on dit depuis
le début d'ailleurs mais c'est pas la
première fois qu'il est posé annoncé et
puis ensuite retirer bon après le choix
de la majorité enfin de députés de la
majorité de signer une tribune avec
l'extrême gauche c'est quelque chose que
moi j'ai beaucoup de mal à comprendre
enfin vous imaginez si d'autres députés
le faisaient avec l'extrême droite ce
serait un scandale national là personne
ne relève ce fait quand même qu'il n'est
pas député les femmes oui mais des gens
qui sont alliés avec l'extrême gauche
alors moi je veux bien qu'on fasse
semblant mais il y a un moment où cette
hypocrisie là il faut la levée donc ça
ça c'est quand même quelque chose qui
moi me paraît absolument désolant la
deuxième chose c'est que on voit bien
que ce texte il est pas prêt d'être voté
en l'état parce que en réalité depuis le
début pour essayer de faire de la
politique aux mauvais sens du terme on a
concilié des choses qui n'ont rien à
voir les métiers en tension c'est pas un
sujet
migratoire c'est un sujet économique et
social c'est qu'est-ce qui fait que il y
a des Français et aujourd'hui ont un
système d'allocation sociale
suffisamment confortable pour refuser
des postes dans un certain nombre de
secteurs c'est ça le sujet c'est un
sujet de formation puis c'est un sujet
de motivation et là j'ai envie de vous
dire c'est quand même d'abord un
problème intérieur imaginez pour ces
métiers là on est besoin d'aller
chercher des salariés venus d'autres
pays c'est aberrant aberrant bon le
deuxième point c'est que notre priorité
numéro 1 c'est la question de la
maîtrise de l'immigration parce que tant
qu'on ne sera pas capable de le faire
tant qu'on sera pas capable d'exécuter
des obligations de quitter le territoire
français tant qu'on ne sera pas capable
de donner plus vite des réponses aux
demandes de de visa et bien on sera dans
cette situation folle qui conduit notre
pays à être en réalité capable de
traiter cette situation est-ce que les
républicains en faisant de ce sujet des
métiers en tension une ligne rouge ne
condamne pas finalement ce texte
d'avoir pour seul vocation de rendre
service enfin c'est tout ça c'est
pourquoi pour que la nuque donc
l'extrême gauche vote enfin on est chez
les dingues c'est pas le sujet le sujet
c'est de traiter les problèmes de la
France je suis maire
j'entendais tout ça Jean-Pierre sure
dire ah ben moi je suis un adepte
interdiction du cumul des mandats il
faut que les mères soient dorés dans
leur coin moi je partage les liens je
partage pas du tout cet avis je pense
bien dommage qu'il n'y ait pas des
maires pour raconter au Sénat et à
l'Assemblée ce qui vivent le
centre-ville de Meaux pour prendre un
exemple très concret aujourd'hui nous
nous trouvons dans une situation ou en
tant que mère nous découvrons après que
des associations mandatées par l'État
loup des maisons ou des appartements
pour y loger des migrants sans aucun
contrôle de rien ni de personnes ou des
mineurs non accompagnés il n'y a
absolument aucune règle dans ce domaine
ni aucune maîtrise est-ce que est-ce que
c'est qu'est-ce que c'est acceptable
est-ce que c'est supportable pour ces
personnes qui sont livrées elles-mêmes
dis donc ils se retrouvent comme elles
peuvent dans un univers qu'elles
connaissent pas du tout et est-ce que
c'est supportable pour des des des
municipalités qui essayent justement de
donner de la cohésion et de la cohérence
à l'action qu'il m'aime c'est ça qui ne
va pas c'est un sujet qui fait réagir
est-ce que vous pensez que les
républicains seront unis cette fois-ci
je pense au députés au sénateur entre
l'Assemblée et le Sénat est-ce qu'il y
aura une même ligne de conduite de la
part des députés des sénateurs LR au
moment des débats où est-ce qu'on va
assister au même phénomène de la réforme
des retraites notre sujet d'abord j'ai
le sentiment qu'il y a une plus grande
quand même cohésion de de des
républicains sur le sujet de
l'immigration que sur le sujet des
retraites mais ce qui est vrai en
revanche c'est qu'il y a
incontestablement aujourd'hui non pas un
LR si je puis dire ou un parti LR ou un
groupe LR mais mais des subdivisions qui
sont très nombreuses entre ceux qui
pensent que nous devons
gouverner au service de la France et
donc être prêt à proposer et même
parfois imposé des projets qui sont
nécessaires pour le pays avec la
majorité actuelle et ceux qui
considèrent qu'il faut tout casser quoi
qu'il arrive en position sauf que les
conditions politiques sont de moins en
moins réunies puisque en réalité ça
dialogue de sourd mais enfin je pense
que c'est ce qu'il fallait faire au
lendemain des législatives parce que la
Cinquième République c'est pas comme la
troisième la troisième elle fonctionnait
sur des combinés de fionnes des
combinaisons
circonstanciées la cinquième elle
fonctionne sur la majorité absolue et
donc depuis le début de ce quinquennat
le malentendu est profond parce qu'il
n'y a pas de majorité absolue pour pour
gouverner Eric ce t-il le président de
votre partie la réponse du la Emmanuel
Macron après les rencontres de syndices
c'est une réponse qui est quand même en
forme d'ultimatum il fixe 4 lignes avec
ce type le pouvoir d'achat d'un sécurité
l'immigration de la liberté de la presse
est-ce qu'il a raison d'être aussi fermé
avec le chat tout à fait raison parce
qu'il faut être clair de la presse
j'avoue que j'ai pas compris mais en
revanche en revanche sur le sur le les
trois points fondamentaux il a
totalement raison pourquoi tout
simplement parce qu'il est impératif
impératif de proposer à Monsieur Macron
quelque chose qui permette à la France
de redémarrer en se redémarrage ne peut
se faire qu'avec une majorité cohérente
sur un nouveau programme les Français
auraient pu donner la majorité absolue à
Emmanuel Macron c'était très facile il
suffisait de voter plus massivement pour
les députés de l'actuel majorité ils
n'ont pas fait c'est absolument fou que
le Président de la République n'est pas
voulu l'entendre c'est quand même un
déni de démocratie de gouverner comment
le fait là sans majorité donc là vous
lui dites Emmanuel Macron en tout cas
vous souhaitez qu'il réponde
favorablement aux quatre coins
d'érection en tout cas que cela débouche
sur un nouveau pacte de gouvernement
parce que sinon c'est quoi le risque
c'est que il y ait des parlementaires
plus ou moins responsables qui disent
puisque c'est ça nous allons voter une
motion de censure ce que dit encore
Aurélien Pradier ce matin
donc ça veut dire que vous savez c'est
c'est comme quand on était plus petit on
jouait aux de la bataille vous savez si
tu mets ça puis tu rajoutes ça et puis
on rajoute ça bon c'est quoi la suite de
l'histoire c'est des enchaînements bien
connu si le gouvernement si l'opposition
LR se joint à d'autres groupes donc y
compris mais mathématiquement extrême
droite extrême gauche pour censurer le
gouvernement sur un texte il n'y a pas
beaucoup de choix pour le président de
la République si ce n'est de devoir
dissoudre mais dissoudre dans une
période où nous connaissons une crise
économique comme celle que nous
connaissons ça veut dire un risque
majeur un de ne pas retrouver de
majorité de devoir la montée des
extrémismes qui incarnerait les
mécontentements ça veut dire
elle risque de faire monter le Front
National
et donc ça ça veut dire que ça nous
oblige quelque part avoir une réflexion
de fond parce que ça veut dire que dans
le même temps on aurait moins de députés
LR une réflexion de fond qui de savoir
est-ce que dans cette perspective on
prépare pas alors les choses on
imaginant des candidatures uniques parce
que sinon on va encore regarder le match
du deuxième tour on ne sera pas qualifié
au deuxième tour et vous voyez les
républicains et Emmanuel Macron sur la
base d'un nouveau pack de gouvernement
qu'on présenterait aux Français avant
mais vous voyez d'ailleurs très bien la
suite de mon raisonnement parce que ce
qui peut s'appliquer à des législatives
anticipées si par malheur on est dans
cette situation de crise politique dont
je répète on a vraiment pas besoin il y
a les JO qui arrivent il y a la crise
financière il y a l'Ukraine enfin
l'étape suivante c'est la présidence on
va avoir combien de candidats dans ce
qu'on appelle pudiquement l'arc
républicain c'est-à-dire les gens qui ne
sont ni d'extrême droite ni d'extrême
gauche vous avez vu le nombre de
candidatures qui émergent en ce moment
on n'est pas loin une candidature unique
entre les République présidentielle à la
présidentielle au-delà d'une candidature
ennemie on n'est pas qualifiée au
deuxième tour donc on se retrouve avec
un risque d'une finale entre le candidat
de LSI et le candidat de du FN vous
imaginez le spectacle et qui est-ce
Édouard Philippe qui est très présent
cette semaine pour être ce candidat
unique du tout ce que je sais c'est
qu'il faut qu'il y en a qu'un parce que
aujourd'hui j'envoie si je lis les
gazettes au moins 6 alors j'ai pas
besoin de vous dire qu'avec 6 candidats
dans le l'arc républicain c'est-à-dire
la partie droite plutôt je laisse de
côté le PS qui sombre mais dans la
partie droite si candidats mais vous
faites comment pour être qualifié parce
que dans sa rentrée au Cannet il a il a
inventé les mér de Laurent Wauquiez
ça doit pas être
vous avez compris que c'était pas mon
point vous pouvez l'appeler Dupont
durant ça ne va pas y avoir de candidats
aujourd'hui 6 vous rendez compte Édouard
Philippe Bruno Le Maire Gérald Darmanin
David Lisnard Xavier Bertrand Laurent
Wauquiez pour prendre tout le spectre et
vous faites comment vous voyez donc on a
aujourd'hui à travers ce qui est en
train de se vivre sur les menaces d'une
motion de censure pouvant donner une
dissolution de l'Assemblée nationale
nous avons en toile de fond ce qui
risque d'arriver pour les
présidentielles donc dans quatre ans
pourquoi est-ce qu'on parle des
présidentielles dans quatre ans mais
c'est tout simplement parce que dès
aujourd'hui il y a une telle instabilité
politique que tout le monde se demande
comment on va tenir 4 ans je rappelle
que quand en 2002 Jacques Chirac avait
été élu après une cohabitation on sait
pas mis à parler de sa succession dès le
lendemain on a fait énormément de
réformes parce qu'il y avait une
majorité absolue très puissante aux
côtés de Jacques Chirac et des
gouvernement de Jean-Pierre une
Dominique de Villepin aujourd'hui nous
n'avons pas cette situation donc autant
vous dire que le point politique on est
aujourd'hui dans un ciel serein où il
peut y avoir à tout moment un vrai coup
de tonnerre comment en fait justement
pour pour gouverner pendant les pendant
ces quatre ans je vais prendre un
exemple la rentrée en juillet vous étiez
félicité de la reprise en main
d'éducation nationale après la
nomination de Gabriela on a vu depuis
que Emmanuel Macron considère que les
enjeux liés à l'école sont tellement
importants qu'il est normal qu'il pilote
directement le sujet c'est celui le
nouveau ministre de l'éducation
nationale il en fait trois ou pas ou
c'est la bonne médecine Emmanuel Macron
ça il a dit c'est normal il adore enfin
je sais normal mais en tout cas il adore
il adore avoir de dire bah ça c'est à
moi c'est mon domaine réservé non
heureusement
il y a dans la tradition républicaine un
domaine réservé qui est acté c'est la
politique étrangère et un peu la défense
dans le sens où là pour le coup de
domaines dans lequel on n'a pas besoin
du Parlement en revanche l'éducation
nationale on a quand même besoin du
Parlement et puis et puis en revanche
moi ce que j'ai dit je le redis c'est
que je pense que Gabriel Attal est
effectivement il l'a montré dans les
premières semaines l'homme de la
situation après le désastre que nous
venons de connaître avec son
prédécesseur il a beaucoup parlé est-ce
qu'il y a pas d'autres priorités
que vous me le demandez ne me dites pas
ça à moi j'ai porté la loi
d'interdiction de la burqa qui était un
déni d'identité pour les femmes c'est le
masque intégral je l'ai fait d'ailleurs
avec l'hostilité à l'époque de de
Sarkozy et de Fillon mais avec le
soutien de mes amis députés de la
majorité qui eux voyaient ça sur le
terrain parce que à l'époque on était
députés et mer et qu'on voyait bien
qu'il y avait une atteinte majeure à la
laïcité donc me demandez pas de de
contrer une mesure de bon sens relative
à la laïcité à l'école de la même
manière il va parler que de ça parce que
je vois bien que sur un certain nombre
de sujets il veut mettre si je puis dire
les pieds dans le plat sur des éléments
qui nous inquiétent tous je pense à la
maîtriser savoir fondamentaux j'espère
qu'il va aller plus loin sur la question
de ce qu'on appelle pour aller vite qui
est une folie parce que dire qu'on a un
même collège avec un même modèle que ce
soit dans un quartier difficile dans un
centre-ville ou dans une zone rurale
c'est nier la réalité des différences de
population pour lesquelles il faut un
enseignement et un projet adapté à
chacun une organisation et donc moi je
rêve que nous ayons des chefs
d'établissement qui soit des vrais chefs
qui puissent recruter leurs équipes
pédagogiques sur la base du volontariat
qu'il soit d'ailleurs évalué aussi sur
la manière dont il procède leur
comportement les résultats c'est majeur
voilà donc voilà des sujets et puis à
notre sujet dont il a parlé là pour le
coup et qui prioritaire absolue c'est la
question du harcèlement et aussi des
addictions nous avons là des phénomènes
de société qu'en tant que mère nous
voyons qui ne remonte pas suffisamment à
Paris et qui sont gravissimes vous avez
évoqué brièvement les quartiers
difficiles juste une question le calme
pour vous le calmer durablement revenu
dans les quartiers après les émeutes de
l'été ou dans un volcan
éternel la réalité c'est que nous
n'avons pas aujourd'hui pris totalement
la mesure de ce qui s'est passé il s'est
passé quoi j'ai eu un rapport qui est
totalement déconnecté enfin je suis
désolé de le dire la réalité c'est que
nous avons des des jeunes assez peu
nombreux mais très jeune totalement
livré à eux-mêmes fonctionnant avec les
réseaux sociaux et quelques meneurs des
comportements de parents abandonnés
irresponsables voire complice je
rappelle que il y a des images vidéos
qui montrent des parents qui suivent
leurs enfants pour aller piller dans des
conditions d'irresponsabilité totale et
avec une police républicaine qu'elle
soit nationale ou municipale qui à
chaque fois qu'elle en a eu des moyens à
remarquablement réagit mais le problème
de fond c'est qu'il faut évidemment
sanctionner les auteurs ça a été fait et
regardez de plus près la responsabilité
des parents parce qu'elle
de même qu'on devrait assumer ce que
dire Bruno Le Maire avait dit en
d'autres temps la fin de l'emploi à vie
pour les nouveaux entrants dans la
fonction publique ce qui permettrait
dans une gestion beaucoup plus souple
des ressources humaines il y a
énormément de domaines dans lequel on a
des pistes d'économie il faut les
assumer parce qu'aujourd'hui le prix
qu'on paye c'est qu'on renonce a baisser
les impôts qui sont très élevés
notamment pour les entreprises alors
qu'on a des besoins de compétitivité
entre les uns les autres vous me
demandez mon avis donc oui bien sûr
qu'il a raison il faut arrêter ces
cadeaux qui sont des one shot et qui en
réalité ont un désastre du point de vue
budgétaire on va parler de votre partie
pour terminer des républicains et des
européennes avant de parler de partie
Marion maréchal a annoncé qu'elle serait
tête de liste pour ces européennes pour
reconquête le parti d'Éric Zemmour c'est
un coup dur pour les républicains
puisque vous me parlez de de Zemmour moi
je vous dis tout de suite je ne
laisserai jamais dire que l'avenir de la
droite républicaine c'est une alliance
avec Zemmour j'ai entendu Nicolas
Sarkozy s'engager dans cette voie
c'est la négation de toutes les valeurs
que nous défendons depuis toujours je
rappelle les propos innombrables je les
rappelle pas vous les avez en tête que
que Zemmour a pu tenir qui sont
contraires à nos convictions y compris
encore récemment sur l'Afrique donc moi
je préfère vous dire tout de suite que
pour moi il n'y a aucune concession à
faire sauf à perdre des élections
accessoirement à être en déni avec nos
valeurs mais à perdre les élections
jamais les Français les millions
d'électeurs qui sont les nôtres qui sont
pour beaucoup des gens qui ont voté
Macron et qui attendent un leader de
droite n'accepteront d'aller lui faire
une alliance avec l'extrême droite
qu'elle soit chez Zemmour ou chez Le Pen
deuxième
comment avoir disparaître les
républiques je vois pas comment les
républicains peuvent survivre à une
alliance avec l'extrême droite ça c'est
voilà et s'il y en a qui ont encore des
doutes ils ont qu'à regarder ce qui se
passe en Espagne en ce qui concerne en
ce qui concerne les Européennes et les
histoires de de choix de candidature de
Zemmour c'est son affaire enfin moi j'ai
pas de j'ai pas de commentaire
particulier à faire elle appelle
François-Xavier Bellamy elle a le
rejoindre à l'appel vos électeurs aller
rejoindre est-ce que c'est quand même un
coup dur est-ce que François-Xavier
Bellamy peut encore être tête de liste
avec Marion maréchal comme concurrent
ceux que Xavier Bellamy d'abord il a il
c'est plus tout à fait la même chose
qu'il y a quelques années deuxièmement
il a travaillé
il connaît bien les sujets européens
maintenant
ce qui n'est pas nécessairement le cas
de candidats d'extrême droite qui ont
des approches assez différentes de la
nôtre et puis voilà et puis on verra
bien mais ce sont des sujets différents
le coup dur il a déjà il a déjà quand il
était candidat à la présidentielle il
appelait déjà à ce type d'alliance et
son républicains peuvent encore se payer
le luxe d'une des confitures aux
européennes ou ce serait le ça sonne
régla du parti bon
il y a pas pire que ce qu'on a vécu au
présidentiel quand même donc on continue
notre descends faire moins de 5%, mais
on a raison mais ce que j'ai assez qu'on
continue à descente aux enfers pour la
raison simple que nous avons une crise
de leadership majeur et que nous ne
sommes pas au clair sur ce que nous
voulons faire pour les Français
par exemple vous souhaitez une liste
unique là aussi puisque vous parliez de
candidature unique pour la vie avec la
majorité présidentielle où est-ce qu'il
faut que la logique absolue si nous
avions fait une majorité en 2022 mais on
l'a pas fait donc on va pas tout d'un
coup
maintenant c'est trop tard en réalité il
faut il faut continuer sur cette
approche et essayer de rassembler le
plus de voix possible
vous le soutenez vous pensez que c'est
le bon côté on n'a pas encore fait le
choix mais je pense que c'est quelqu'un
que c'est quelqu'un de valeur
François-Xavier Bellamy encore une fois
je répète il a travaillé il était
quelqu'un d'extrêmement sérieux voilà
après j'en sais rien à vous dire je
c'est pas celui qui a pas été abordé je
sais même pas qui sont les éventuels
autres candidats
je sais pas je j'en connais pas est-ce
que les républicains sont prêts pour ces
européennes vous savez sur l'Europe on a
toujours eu nous un discours assez assez
courageux quand même c'est qu'on est au
piétine toute la journée mais enfin on
oublie tout ce qui a été dit tout ce qui
a été fait pour l'Europe nous sommes un
parti profondément européen et en même
temps parfaitement lucide sur le rôle
que la France doit jouer pour préserver
sa souveraineté donc c'est ça qui est
notre notre particularité merci
Jean-François Copé merci beaucoup
d'avoir été notre invité Stéphane on
regarde la Une de Ouest-France séisme
pourquoi le Maroc filtre l'aide
internationale c'est à la Une de votre
journal et puis votre livre Stéphane
déjeuner secret dans les coulisses de la
réforme des retraites c'est aux édition
Ouest-France hors librairie depuis
vendredi oui pour tout savoir de ce qui
s'est passé on hâte de voir ça Stéphane
merci beaucoup merci Jean-François Copé